>>> WE DO HAVE BREAKING NE
TONIGHT ON THE LEGAL FIGHT OVE
THE DOCUMENTS RETRIEVED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
TWO BIG DEVELOPMENTS, BOTH GOING
AGAINST THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT.
ONE INVOLVING ITS ATTEMPT TO
RESUME ITS INVESTIGATION INTO
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S HANDLING
OF THE CLASSIFIED RECORDS.
THE OTHER THE APPOINTMENT OF THE
SPECIAL MASTER TO REVIEW THOSE
DOCUMENTS.
CNN'S SARA MURRAY JOINS US NOW
WITH THE LATEST THERE.
SARAH, WHAT CAN YOU TELL US
ABOUT THIS RULING FROM JUDGE
CANNON?
>> WELL, LOOK, WE FINALLY HEARD
WHO THE SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING
TO BE.
IT'S GOING TO BE JUDGE RAYMOND
DEAR.
HE IS THE ONLY PERSON THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND THE TRUMP
TEAM AGREED ON.
SO IN SOME WAYS, THAT IS NOT
SURPRISING.
NOW WHAT THE GOVERNMENT WANTED
HER TO DO, THEY WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO MOVE FORWARD WITH THEIR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION.
THEY SAID LOOK, IF YOU PUT
FORWARD A SPECIAL MASTER, AT
LEAST DON'T HAVE THE SPECIAL
MASTER GO OVER THE 100
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS WE FOUND AT
MAR-A-LAGO AFTER THE AUGUST
SEARCH.
THE JUDGE IS SAYING NO DICE.
THE SPECIAL MASTER IS GOING TO
REVIEW ALL OF THESE DOCUMENTS.
YOU ARE NOT ALLOWED TO CONTINUE
REVIEWING THESE DOCUMENTS AS
PART OF YOUR CRIMINAL PROBE.
SHE IS SAYING LOOK, THERE IS
STILL OTHER STUFF YOU CAN DO
WITHOUT HAVING ACCESS TO THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THERE ARE STILL WITNESSES YOU
CAN QUESTION.
THE YOU CAN STILL BRIEF CONGRESS
ON THESE MATERIALS, BUT YOU
CANNOT BE HANDLING THESE
DOCUMENTS, SHOWING THEM TO
WITNESS, PRESENTING THEM BEFORE
A GRAND JURY, THINGS THAT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT WOULD LIKE TO
DO AS PART OF THEIR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
AND ESSENTIALLY SHE SAYS SHE
REALLY DOESN'T BUY DOJ'S
ARGUMENT THAT NOT BEING ABLE TO
ACCESS THESE DOCUMENTS WOULD
IMPEDE THE NATIONAL SECURITY
DAMAGE ASSESSMENT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
VERY GOOD EXPLANATION THERE,
SARA.
WHAT HAPPENS NEXT?
HOW LIKELY IS IT THAT THE DOJ
WILL APPEAL?
>> WELL, DOJ BASICALLY TOLD HER,
LOOK, HERE IS WHAT WE WANT.
WE WANT THIS CARVEOUT FOR OUR
CRIMINAL INVESTIGATION TO GO
FORWARD.
WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THESE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS.
TELL US BY TODAY WHAT YOUR
DECISION IS.
AND IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO AGREE
TO THIS, IF YOU'RE NOT GOING TO
AGREE TO LET OUR CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION GO FORWARD, THEN
WE ARE GOING TO APPEAL.
SO THEY SORT OF SHOWED THEIR
CARDS IN THAT SENSE.
WE HAVE NOT SEEN THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT'S APPEAL, BUT THEY
DID GIVE AN INDICATION BEFORE WE
GOT THIS DECISION FROM THE JUDGE
THAT THAT IS WHAT THEIR PATH IS
GOING TO BE.
>> SARA MURRAY, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
AND THANK YOU DURING THE ENTIRE
BREAK EXPLAINING TO ME THE
LANGUAGE IN THE RULING FROM THE
JUDGE THAT I WAS CONFUSED BY.
VERY MUCH APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANKS, JOHN.
>>> PERSPECTIVE NOW FROM
CONSERVE LAWYER JOHN CONAWAY,
CONTRIBUTING COLUMNIST AT "THE
WASHINGTON POST" AND JOHN YU,
FORMER DEPUTY ATTORNEY GENERAL
DURING THE GEORGE BUSH
ADMINISTRATION, NOW A LAW SCHOOL
PROFESSOR AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AT BERKELEY.
AND GEORGE, I JUST WANT TO START
WITH YOU.
HOW MUCH OF A SETBACK IS THIS
FOR THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE A HUGE SETBACK IN
LONG-TERM, BUT IT'S GOING TO
DELAY THEM TO SOME EXTENT.
I MEAN, THIS RULING IS
ABSOLUTELY A DISGRACE.
AND I DON'T THINK IT'S GOING TO
TAKE VERY MUCH TO OVERTURN IT.
I MEAN, BILL BARR LAST WEEK TOLD
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" THAT THE
ORIGINAL MOTION BY DONALD
TRUMP'S LAWYERS WAS A CROCK OF
SHIT, A CROCK OF SHIT.
THAT'S WHAT HE SAID TO "THE NEW
YORK TIMES."
THIS OPINION IS WORSE THAN THAT
BECAUSE THIS OPINION FOCUSES ON
EMOTION, DECIDES EMOTION THAT IS
FOCUSED ON JUST THE DOCUMENTS
THAT WERE MARKED CLASSIFIED.
AND THE JUDGE CLAIMS IN THIS
OPINION, WITHOUT ANY BASIS, THAT
THERE ARE FACTUAL AND LEGAL
DISPUTES ABOUT THOSE DOCUMENTS.
WELL, THERE ARE NO FACTUAL
DISPUTES ABOUT WHETHER A
DOCUMENT BEARS CLASSIFIED
MARKINGS.
THAT'S RIDICULOUS.
AND THERE IS NO DISPUTE THAT A
DOCUMENT TAKEN FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE, STOLEN FROM THE WHITE
HOUSE THAT BELONGS, THAT WAS
PREPARED BY GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS, NATIONAL SECURITY
OFFICIALS, THERE IS NO DISPUTE
THAT THOSE DOCUMENTS BELONG TO
THE GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED
STATES.
AND EVEN TRUMP'S LAWYERS DID NOT
ACTUALLY MAKE THE SPECIFIC CLAIM
THAT THESE DOCUMENTS WERE
SOMEHOW MAGICALLY DECLASSIFIED
BY THE BRAINWAVES OF DONALD
TRUMP.
IT JUST WASN'T.
AND AS YOUR COLLEAGUES FOUND,
JAMIE GANGEL AND OTHERS, 18 --
18 TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS LAUGHED AT THE
PROPOSITION THAT THESE DOCUMENTS
WERE DECLASSIFIED.
AND IT DOESN'T EVEN MATTER
WHETHER THESE DOCUMENTS WERE
DECLASSIFIED BECAUSE THE CHARGES
AT ISSUE HERE DON'T DEAL WITH
CLASSIFICATION.
THEY DEAL WITH NATIONAL SECURITY
INTERESTS.
THIS OPINION IS ABSOLUTELY
ATROCIOUS.
AND I HAVE TO SAY -- AND I'VE
NEVER SAID THIS PUBLICLY ABOUT A
FEDERAL JUDGE IN MY LIFE, YOU
HAVE TO WONDER WHETHER THIS
JUDGE BELONGS ON A FEDERAL
BENCH.
>> SO, JOHN, GEORGE HAS MADE HIS
OPINION QUITE CLEAR HERE.
AND HE QUOTED BILL BARR.
NEITHER OF THEM SIT ON THE 11th
CIRCUIT.
SO THE QUESTION TO YOU, DO YOU
THINK THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE WILL OR SHOULD APPEAL?
AND DO YOU THINK THEY HAVE A
CHANCE OF GETTING A MOTHER
FAVORABLE RULING FROM A HIGHER
COURT?
>> JOHN, THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
ALREADY PROMISED THAT IT WOULD
APPEAL.
AND THE JUDGE, I'M NOT SURPRISED
THAT JUDGE CANNON DID THAT,
BECAUSE THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
WAS BASICALLY ASKING HER TO
REVERSE MUCH OF HER DECISION,
THE MOST IMPORTANT PART RELATED
TO CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
SO THE INTERESTING THING IS ON
APPEAL, THE 11th CIRCUIT WILL
LOOK AT WHAT POWER DID JUDGE
CANNON HAVE TO UNDERTAKE THIS
REMARKABLE AND EXTRAORDINARY
STEP, WHICH TO INTRODUCE A THIRD
PARTY, THIS SPECIAL MASTER INTO
A TYPE OF SITUATION WHERE WE
RARELY EVER SEE THEM.
ON THE OTHER HAND, APPELLATE
COURTS DON'T REALLY LIKE TO
SECOND GUESS TRIAL COURTS WHEN
THEY'RE MANAGING THINGS LIKE
SEARCH AND SEIZURES, WHEN
CRIMINAL TRIALS.
AND THE RULE OF PROCEDURE HERE
GIVES TRIAL JUDGES THE
DISCRETION IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES WHICH JUDGE CANNON
HERE FOUND TO APPOINT A SPECIAL
MASTER.
THE WAY YOU MIGHT THINK OF IT IS
ARE WE GOING TO PREVENT THIS
TRIAL JUDGE FROM ASKING FOR THE
HELP OF A SPECIAL MASTER,
SOMEONE LIKE JUDGE DIERE, WHO IS
FAMILIAR WITH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION AND HAS SERVED ON
THE FOREIGN INTELLIGENCE
SURVEILLANCE CORE.
BECAUSE IF THEY SAY NO, THE
JUDGE IS GOING TO GO AHEAD AND
DECIDE THE ISSUES HERSELF ANY
WAY.
I THINK THE BETTER THING IS TO
WORK WITH THE SPECIAL MASTER,
ACCELERATE THE REVIEW OF THE
DOCUMENTS.
I BET THEY COULD EVEN GET
THROUGH ALL THE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS IN THE TIME IT WOULD
TAKE TO APPEAL TO THE 11th
CIRCUIT AND WAIT FOR A RULING
ANY WAY?
>> WHAT ABOUT THAT?
THE JUDGE ORDERED TO PRIORITIZE
THE DECLASSIFIED FIRST.
COULD THAT SPEED THINGS UP?
>> OH, YES.
THAT'S THE LITTLE AREA OF GIVE
THAT I SAW IN THE OPINION THAT
WENT -- THAT SHOWED SOME EFFORT
TO COMPROMISE HERE BY JUDGE
CANNON.
SHE DIDN'T JUST FLATLY REJECT
THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ENTIRELY.
SHE SAID I AM GOING TO TELL THE
SPECIAL MASTER TO LOOK AT THE
100 CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FIRST
AND TRY TO PRIORITIZE THEM AND
SPEED THROUGH THEM.
AND PART THIS BECAUSE THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT ALREADY SAID
WE'RE CONTENT TO NOT USE THE
OTHER THOUSANDS OF PAGES THAT
AREN'T CLASSIFIED, AND WE WILL
AGREE TO THE DISTRICT JUDGE'S
ORDER THAT WE NOT USE THOSE AT
ALL IN ANY CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATION.
>> SO, GEORGE, ON ANOTHER NOTE,
THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS ON HUGH
HEWITT'S RADIO SHOW TODAY.
I WANT TO PLAY A PORTION OF WHAT
HE SAID WHEN ASKED WHAT WOULD
HAPPEN IF HE WAS INDICTED, AND
IF IT WOULD DETER HIM FROM
RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT AGAIN.
LISTEN TO THIS.
>> I THINK IF IT HAPPENED, I
THINK YOU'D HAVE PROBLEMS IN
THIS COUNTRY THE LIKES OF WHICH
PERHAPS WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
I DON'T THINK THE PEOPLE OF THE
UNITED STATES WOULD STAND FOR
IT.
>> WHAT KIND OF PROBLEMS, MR.
PRESIDENT?
>> I THINK YOU'D HAVE BIG
PROBLEMS.
BIG PROBLEMS.
I JUST DON'T THINK THEY'D STAND
FOR IT.
>> WHAT DO YOU HEAR THERE,
GEORGE?
DO YOU HEAR THAT AS A THREAT?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
I MEAN, HE IS BASICALLY SAYING
WHAT A NICE COUNTRY YOU HAVE
HERE.
TOO BAD IF SOMETHING WOULD
HAPPEN TO IT.
AND IT'S BASICALLY JANUARY 6th
ALL OVER AGAIN.
HE'S DENYING INCITING VIOLENCE,
BUT THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS HE
IS INCITING VIOLENCE BECAUSE
HE'S BASICALLY SAYING HE'S
CONVINCED MILLIONS OF PEOPLE
THAT HE IS BEING PERSECUTED FOR
NO VALID REASON.
WHERE WHEN IN FACT HE KNOWS, AND
HE'S TERRIFIED ABOUT THE FACT
THAT HE HAS BEEN CAUGHT STEALING
RED-HANDED STEALING GOVERNMENT
DOCUMENTS OF THE HIGHEST,
HIGHEST SECURITY NATURE.
AND IT'S JUST -- BY
PERPETRATORING THAT LIE TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, HE IS
AB